les drôles de félicitations d'un député
finlandais à emmanuel macron le
centriste pétri en connaît a reproduit
la photo du président réélu celle qui
avait tant fait parler pendant l'autre
de tours la pause est là la chemise
blanche aussi mais elle devrait être
plus ouverte lui font remarquer des
internautes sur son tweet c'est la
timidité finlandaise at il répondu
question bouton le vice premier ministre
de belgique a clairement joué le jeu
avec ce cliché accompagné d'un trait
d'humour c'est comme ça qu'on gagne les
élections ces jours ci vous aviez voté
au premier tour quand même j'ai voté au
premier tour ni la gauche
n'ont alors pas du tout non non non j'ai
pas voté pour pour ma mère j'ai voté
pour jean luc mélenchon mais pas par
gross conviction en réalité c'était pas
parce que je trouvais que ce qu'il
disait était géniale particulièrement
mais son idée de faire une sixième
république je me suis dit que ça pouvait
être un moyen pour que les gens se
posent des questions sur le système dans
sa globalité 41 milliards d'euros c'est
notre chiffre des jurés c'est la seule
mise sur la table par elad meuse pour
s'offrir twitter après mot de
négociation son offre a été acceptée
l'homme le plus riche du monde compte
bien transformer son acquisition
révolution et y apporter sa touche en
premier lieu en faire la plateforme de
la liberté d'expression
regardons sacha regarde six ans
américaine courageuse qui n'hésite pas à
s'afficher avec le pull de son grand
père décédé quelques jours auparavant et
ce malgré les 30 degrés qu'il fait
dehors il y à aussi du commissaire
assumer guapa britannique 23 ans elle
aussi se montre pleurs dans son lit le
lendemain d'une rupture avec son petit
ami et encore il y à kayes legs jeune
américaine du wisconsin qui elle aussi
s'est fait larguer
recettes
ne prenons pas ce phénomène à la légère
les #tours stains cup et aux piqûres cry
pleurer comptabilise trêve 1 milliard de
vues sur la plateforme qu'il s'agit
d'une séparation d'un deuil ou de la
perte d'un proche d'un deuil c'est la
même chose en tout est bon pour exposer
sa peine nous soyons pas naïfs par
ricochet cette quête d'authenticité
intéresse dans tout six sites de type 2
peuvent visionner intéresse aussi les
marques la compassion est un business
comme un autre j'ai passé un super bon
moment et
c'était fan fan mais j'ai pas eu des
papillons dans ma vie
[Musique]
j'ai papillon ça veut dire je risque pas
de tomber amoureuse de toi je suis
désolé
bonjour annick oui bonjour donc free
julien oui là c'est julian et qu'il sait
très bien d'ailleurs je suis parti un
peu précipitamment ce matin je n'étais
pas fait bizarre tu m'excuses annick
oui bien sûr bon c'est gentil avec red
bull a poussé un peu trop loin le
curseur de l'extrême plus de pilotes et
parachutistes ont tenté de réaliser un
plein soit un échange d'avions au-dessus
du désert de l'arizona chacun a sauté en
plein vol avec pour objectif de
rejoindre l'avion de l'autre et d'en
reprendre les commandes
l'un d'eux a bien réussi
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il s'est passé
un truc avec les deux mains je suis très
fleur bleue vous qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti je pencherais plutôt pour le
deuxième pour bernard
et ouais moi je suis assez d'accord vous
voudriez avoir qui à la maison dimanche
pour le poulet frites
à qui mange pas beaucoup
pour l'autre ce fut beaucoup plus
compliqué l'engin s'est mis à briller et
s'est finalement écrasé
et le pilote a dû finir son saut en
parachute